Hey guys, we're about to start a show today on the show that's called SmartList that we're all part of and right before we do the show, we do this little intro thing that's really interesting and fun to do just because we need to come over and fucking give you a hug. What is happening? We started too early. It's 12.20. Yeah, you're falling apart. Welcome to SmartList.
We had two shows today and we just had a little break and what did you do in your break? I'll tell you exactly what I did. I made a couple eggs, put some avocado and some toast, put it all together and I put it in my goddamn mouth. First of all, to be fair, you weren't really asking what we did. Yeah, I was wondering. You just tell us. So don't dress it up as a question like, what did you guys do?
What I did was blah, blah, blah, that's all you wanted. You just wanted to tell us that. Yes, exactly. And he probably spent the whole hour in between the two podcasts recording going, boy, what should I start off the chat with? Oh, I know. I'll just tell him what I ate. That'll be a great conversation starter.
Sean, you're the worst. Also, Sean, we don't live in like 1950s connected to New York where we don't have access to avocado. Anybody can get an avocado now. So it's not a big deal. And you're not supposed to give any thought, you're not supposed to pre-think what we're going to be talking about. I'm not.
I literally just sat down. I climbed like, I'm still wiping the eggs off my face. I'm just saying, it's a pretty, what the kids would say, pretty weird flex. Oh. So just if we're being fair. All right. So what did you do? Oh, so now it is a topic of conversation.
I'm going to go with it. Some charity. I just went and did some charity. Oh, did you help some people out? Yep. I went and helped. I know, you know what I did? I made Archie some toast and a little bit of breakfast.
And everybody's carbo-loading. When's the big race, guys? When's the big race? Yes. I worked. I worked. Hang on, Sean. Hang on, Sean.
Oh, did you? Yeah. Doing what? I was watching a cut of episode 407 of Ozark. Ozark? Yeah. You know what? I'll agree with you.
Watching Ozark is work. I agree with you. Oh. I walked right into it. I deserve it. Are you, Jason, can you feel the, like can you see the barn door from here at the end of Ozark? How are you feeling right now?
Emotionally about it for real? Barn door. I love it. I'm feeling great about it because I feel like we did, you know, it's just, we remember we talked about in the last episode about trying to make a friend of mortality and hoping that you at least used your years correctly. It's kind of like what this is, like, you know, the show's not going to go on forever. So when it comes to an end, you'd want to look back and hope that you're proud of it.
And I think we all are. And you're directing the last episode as well, right? Yeah. Oh, that's cool. Yeah. Which is awesome. And I wish, I always say this to you. I love your episodes that you direct.
I always notice a difference. I do like them. It's hard for me to give you that compliment. Thank you. But would you... What I'm ready for the butt. Here it comes. No.
Do you feel added pressure now? I mean, it's like a little bit of like the leave. Like what is the leave that, you know? The only thing that I'm trying to focus on is, you know, the writers specifically Chris Mundy just did a great job of sort of trying to land the plane correctly, you know, in his mind with the story and the themes and all that stuff. And he really, they really did. And so I'm just hoping that, you know, we don't screw it up with the way we acted or
photographed. To service that. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, service. When do I pitch my part? Like for the finale? Gosh. I don't want to come in at the finale.
November would probably be a good... Do you have a webcam? Are you comfortable self-tapping? I'll do it, right? Okay. I had... Jason, it's funny you asked that because now that I realized that I shouldn't have said that to you.
I'm, you know, I'm doing this. I just know I'm doing this Netflix show, this new show, and it's kind of like improv-y and whatever. And I had this lovely sound guy saying to me yesterday, at the end of our first week, and he's putting my mic on, and he goes, man, you got to do a lot. You got to know all that dialogue, and then you got to improvise, and you got to do all this stuff. And he goes, huh, I mean, it's a lot of pressures on you to really make sure the pressure is
really on you as I'm starting the day at 7 a.m., and I look at him and I'm like, he's a great guy. I'm like, what are you doing, man? I got to... Thanks. Thanks for reminding me. It cost me $50. It cost me $50, but he was open to it.
I'm so stressed out. I started the day like in a whole, like walking towards it, I was like, it is on me. I got to... Boy, I really got to step up on this next scene. It's all on you. Anyway, while talking about stepping up in filmmaking and pressure, we're going to find out if our guest today feels any pressure. He...
Probably asleep by now. Sorry, sorry, guest. He could be. But I will say this. I'll tell you what I don't do is I don't fall asleep when I'm watching his films. He has been making incredible films for a long time for many, many years. He's originally from New York and then lives in New Hampshire. He's a filmmaker who's made, put it this way, he's garnered a bunch of awards, including
two Oscar nominations, two Grammy Awards, 15 Emmy Awards. He has made some of the, you know, probably the best documentaries any of us has ever watched throughout the course of our lives, from Brooklyn Bridge to Statue of Liberty, to baseball, to Civil War, and to now the new Muhammad Ali documentary that's coming out this fall. Ken Burns. Ladies and gents. Ken Burns.
Wow. My God. Good Lord. Ken Burns. Wow. And he's in a booth. I love this. This is so cool.
I've seen so many of your films. It's so great to meet you. Yeah. It's my pleasure. It's great to be with you today. Yeah. Super cool. I will say that you, sir, are responsible for my addiction to baseball.
I followed every sport a little bit for my whole life up until about 20 years ago. And maybe it's more than that now. Maybe 25 years ago when I saw the baseball documentary, multi, multi, multi-part documentary. And now I, that's all I follow because you, that series of documentaries, got me to see it more as a game as opposed to a sport and all the history and the pageantry and the elegance of it. Yeah. And all the people you got to speak about it.
Thank you for that. A moment. Well, that's great. You know, it's the only, it's the best game that's ever been invented. That's for sure. And it's so interesting that we don't sort of think about the obvious that there's, this is the only sport in which the defense has the ball. Yeah.
Yeah. And, and you know, it's not the, not the ball or the puck or the, or the, you know, pig skin that scores, it's, it's the person. Yeah. And there's, and there's no time limit, you know, we're there till there's a winner. Yeah. You know what, by the way, but while we're disparaging other sports and I'm going to excuse the, the shot at hockey, Ken, because I'm such an incredible fan of yours and he
will climb through the mic. He's a crazy Canadian. I have such reverence for what you do. Football, it occurred to me last year that American football, and I want to hear your views on this because, because you're a very learned man. American football, only like three people ever touched the ball. So you can be a guy who's a lineman on either side, pick your side, by the way, defensive or offensive lineman, and you can have a Hall of Fame career.
Yeah. I played 18 years in the NFL and you never touched the ball. So are you a football player or are you a wrestler? Yeah. Yeah. It's, it's okay. But, you know, George Wills had a great line about that in our baseball series. He said that, that football has two of the worst habits in American life, a frequent
committee meetings punctuated by violence. That's funny. That's the perfect description. Now, let me ask you, first of all, I want to say this, you're standing, you're, you're in a booth. Are you standing in the booth? I'm sitting in a booth. Okay.
On a stool. On a stool. You have incredible posture. You have incredible posture. You have the posture of somebody who's standing. Cause I often stand. I can put a book on my head if you guys want to keep up with the finishing school aspects of this.
No, no. But I wanted to say that you, I love that you're in a booth. It really tickles me. So I am going to kind of, we're going to jump all over the place a little bit. And the reason I bring it up is your films are such incredible films. And you've told so many great stories and so many aspects of, and I'm getting this a little bit later, of American life. You've dissected so many different areas that have, you know, represent a real cross-section
of kind of what makes America America or makes Americans American. But in order to, to tell that, those stories over the, and by the way, Jason and I hate the term storytellers, but truly you do tell a story. And you, you use narrators and voiceover artists who aren't necessarily voiceoverers. And what I'm getting to is this, it's two part. It's like, by the way, this question is 12 part. I'm familiar with that. Yes.
The first voiceover, I think that you, you, was David McCullough the first real narrator that you had for one of your films? Yeah. He, I got him to narrate the, you know, I filmed him on camera and I was hoping that he could be the third person, the narrator of it. And for a while his folks were sort of, we don't know, but I'd, I'd always, I always knew that in most cases I needed to have a complimentary chorus of first person voices that would read the letters.
Now that's not true in, in my most recent film made with Sarah Burns and David McMahon on, on Muhammad Ali, but if it warrants it, if it's a place, I'm just finishing a film on Benjamin Franklin and Mandipa Tanken is the voice of Franklin and there's several other people who are reading first person in addition to, to Peter Coyote doing the third person. In the case of Ali, it's Keith David, but David did the first five or six of the first seven films and stopped at Civil War. And stopped at Civil War.
So David, David McCullough, if you guys don't know who he is, you know, incredible historian and your relationship, am I right, your relationship started because you're the document you did on the Brooklyn Bridge was based on his book. Is that right? Well, not, but I, I was given his book called The Great Bridge, the epic story of the building of the Brooklyn Bridge and I literally finished it in one gulp and I said to my partners, we just started our company in the mid seventies and I just said, you know, and we all lived in the same apartment.
This is our next film and they looked at me like I was crazy, like I was trying to sell them the Brooklyn Bridge, but he had made that story come alive. So the film I made, the first half is the history, the second half, this is an hour long film, I probably couldn't do an hour long film to save my life now, was sort of the response to it in the last century of, you know, just ingenuity and hope and promise and the way it's been a backdrop for so many things good and bad. So it's not sort of based on that. He just told the best story of how it got built and, and I, I got him to narrate and
he taught us a lot in the course of narrating about writing, which was a hugely great thing and he appeared on camera and then went on to narrate the shakers and Huey Long and the Statue of Liberty and the Congress and the Civil War. And I made a couple others in there and he didn't do it. And you're right. He is a great story too. Even when he gives speeches, when he accepts awards and stuff, his speeches, his speech writing is excellent and his cadence and everything that about his voice also is really
interesting. And he gave me a really hard time when I said I wanted to use McCulloch because they presumed that you would use an actor, you know, out of that stable of narrator, Alexander Scurby, Orson Welles, kind of deep, basso profondo kind of voice. And I said, no, this guy knows the story. Well, isn't it better to inhabit the meaning of it so completely and fully? And well, I have then moved and continued to use like amazing people, Sally Kellerman has been a narrator in a film besides Keith David and Peter Coyote, who are great actors
in their own right. They're, you know, we've just had Jason Robards has read, Aussie Davis has been a narrator. He narrated a film on Thomas Jefferson in the first question at the television critics. Some guys said, hey, you know, Aussie Davis is black. And I went, what? He's black? Yeah. Right.
Who did the narrating in baseball? I want to say, I want to say John Chancellor, but that's, that's you. You got it right. I do. It was so funny because when McCulloch said, you know, I'm going to go on and do something else. And he's, you know, he's a writer that this was, you know, I was taking him away from the day job.
And somebody had said, I'd heard that somebody told me that John Chancellor was from Pittsburgh, where David was from. So I tried out Chancellor. It was funny because he had, I really had to, to the late John Chancellor, really wonderful human being. I really had to sort of break him like a wild horse of the kind of announcer's voice. So the baseball series begins and he would read it. In 1909, a man named Charles Hercules Ebbets began secretly buying up adjacent parcels
of land in the Flatbush section of Brooklyn, including the site of a garbage dump called Pig... How do you remember that? The pigs that once ate their fill there and the stench that still filled the air. Oh, remember that word? Perfect. How do you... Because I'm the scratch narrator.
I read it. I read it for all the folks. Of course. He lays down all the scratchers. That's amazing. I can go on. But what happened is I broke him and I, and so I said, look, he's just talking to your grandchildren.
Just let, make sure they lean in. So he goes in 1909, a man named Charles Hercules Ebbets began, and like that he goes, oh, you want me to be God's stenographer, none of the ego, all of the meaning. And I go, that's it. Yeah. I just want to say the one more. So my last thing on that is I, as a voice guy, a guy who's made a lot of my career around my voice.
I am such a fan of David McCulloch, it's funny to say, because he's not, that's not what he does. That is not his day job. And I think he's so excellent at it. And I remember actually right after 9-11, somebody put out a commercial, it was like the first, do you remember that? And they used his voice to kind of calm America down. They said, everybody, everything's going to be okay.
Everybody relaxed. Yeah, he's the perfect guy to tell us. It's totally perfect. And it was so funny, the grief I got just because he didn't have the credentials. I said, he knows this story cold. He knows American history. As a voiceover guy, I would say he's one of the best. You're like, this guy, he's just got it.
He's up there. He's in the pants on. Sorry, Sean, I keep coming up. No, that's okay. I'm fascinated with your work ethic. And because you've done so many films and your work life balance, it just seems like I want to know how you do it. I want to know production and like, because you have so many films coming out.
You've done so many films. How do you do it? So work life balance, that's really great. So you should have told me I'd get both my ex-wives here and they could tell you about that. You know, look, I just turned 68 and I'm so greedy. I've got, I'm working on seven films, not counting Muhammad Ali, which I'm in the evangelical stage.
I have different teams. I've had two or three teams for an awfully long time. It's just like, you know, if I were given a thousand years to live, I wouldn't run out of topics in American history. And so, you know, we're pretty good at generaling and marshaling our resources. So, you know, we're shooting a few, we're in pre-production in a few, we're editing three, you know, and I just move, I never miss an important thing. And I delegate some stuff that I used to do obsessively before, but that's healthy,
you know, and the other thing is, I'm telling the same story over and over again. And each film asks a deceptively simple question. Who are we? Who are these strange and complicated people who like to call themselves Americans? And what does an investigation of the past tell us about not only that moment, that event, but where we are now and where we may be going. And so, you don't ever answer the question. You sound it deeply in each one and they're recurring themes.
You know, everybody says, well, history repeats itself. Of course it doesn't, there's never been a moment when history has repeated itself. But Mark Twain is supposed to have said, it doesn't repeat itself, but it rhymes. And that's a really good way of doing it. You begin to appreciate the rhymes, race, for example. You make a film on Thomas Jefferson, here's a guy who distills a century of enlightenment thinking into one sentence that begins, we hold these truths to be self-evident that all men are created equal and yet he owned hundreds of human beings in his lifetime and
didn't see the hypocrisy of the contradiction. And so, we have a nation that is, you know, up until now and tomorrow, completely struggling to deal with the question of race. And so, I can think of a handful of films of the nearly 40 that I've done that don't do it. I could count on the fingers of one hand, the films that aren't about it. Yeah, of course. And it plays a big role.
And I know that you've discussed that and you've discussed recently this idea of, you know, people sort of stepping up and saying, why should a white filmmaker like you be the guy telling these stories and stuff? And I know that also your answer is, well, we all have questions to ask and why can't we all play a part in asking those questions? And it's just as valid for me to ask, is anybody else? And I'm sorry, I'm not putting words in your mouth. You can tell me if.
Yeah, no, no, no. I think it's important to tell a lot of stories, but I also think it's important to remember that we're all in this together and connected. And I just came across, it's so interesting that you just brought that up because I came across this great, just a couple of days ago, this great quote by Martin Luther King that is so totally to this. This is what he said. It's just so, it's so perfect.
He goes, all life is interrelated. All people are caught in an inescapable network of mutuality tied in a single garment of destiny. Whatever affects one directly affects all indirectly. I can never be what I ought to be until you are what you ought to be. And you can never be what you ought to be until I am what I ought to be. This is the interrelated structure of reality, which means is my beats American history. And I can't say I'm only going to do one sort of thing because the warp and woof of it is so intertwined and so interconnected that how can you not?
He goes, all life is interrelated. All people are caught in an inescapable network of mutuality tied in a single garment of destiny. Whatever affects one directly affects all indirectly. I can never be what I ought to be until you are what you ought to be. And you can never be what I ought to be until I am what I ought to be. This is the interrelated structure of reality, which means is my beats American history. And I can't say I'm only going to do one sort of thing because the warp and woof of it is so intertwined and so interconnected that how can you not?
And I don't go looking for it in most cases. Obviously, if I pick jazz or I pick Jackie Robinson or Jack Johnson or in this case, Muhammad Ali, it's going to be dealing with the question of race, but so does the Civil War. So does every other film we've made. Yeah. And like you said, it comes up a lot because it is such an integral part. It's woven into the fabric of this, of America. It's part of it.
You can't escape it. It's our original sin. Yeah. It's the original sin. We're under the thrall of three viruses right now, the COVID and a 402-year-old virus of white supremacy and racial intolerance started in 1619 and then an age old human one that everybody's been writing about and talking about it, which is misinformation and lies and paranoia and conspiracy.
And when they meet together, it's just a shit show. Also the other title of our show. Yeah. The shit show. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. You've been making films about the American experience and about America for the, you know, whatever, it's been over 40 years.
Do you have a cynical view now of where we're headed and where we've come from? Is it doom and gloom or do you feel okay? Well I don't think anybody has the luxury at this moment of being cynical. Cynical's a, you know, like just debauchery is just a luxury of too much time and too many things that you're not doing with your hands that you begin doing with your hands. It's really serious. There are three great crises before this, the Civil War, the Depression and World War II.
This is equal to it. And it's the first time that we've got, Lincoln gave this great talk when he was very, very young to the young men's lyceum on a Saturday afternoon, I think it was. And people will write in and tell you that that wasn't a Saturday afternoon. It was an afternoon conversation about foreign policy. He said, this is when he's like not even 29, he's a lawyer in Springfield. He said, when shall we expect the approach of danger? Shall some transatlantic giant step the earth and crush us at a blow?
And then he answered his own question, never all the armies of Europe, Asia and Africa could not by force take a drink from the Ohio river or make a track in the Blue Ridge in the trial of a thousand years. If destruction be our lot, we must ourselves be its author and finisher. As a nation of free men, we will live through all time or die by suicide. And we're, you know, we're looking right down the muzzle of that gun. That quote is so great. It's also, there's a band called Titus Andronicus and they actually have that quote.
Have you ever heard that song? Yes. It's pretty cool the way they use it. It's really cool. That's the way I opened the Civil War series. I mean, it's the end of the intro and you just kind of like, oh, that's right. You know, we got these two great oceans that provide this kind of geographical force field and two relatively benign neighbors north and south that, that provide the same thing.
And so if, if we're going to hell, it's from within. Yeah. And that's what's the biggest. Ken, tell, if you would tell Jason what the Civil War is, um, well, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's said of criminal prosecution, there's civil, is it, is it like a courtroom drama that you've written? That's right. It's, it's, yeah, that's right.
It's about people fighting politely. That you've written. Is Corbyn Burson in it? Yes, yes, right. Yeah. Yes. I'm in. Exactly.
Yeah. You're totally in. With all of your passion and respect, um, for, for America and, and its history and its promise and its idea, uh, and, and all the sort of altruism you've, you've shown us with the stuff that you've given us to watch and learn from, do you feel a sense of urgency right now to speak even louder and work even quicker with something because obviously what you do take so much time and so much care that even if you started something, you know, on January 7th to address the crescendo that we seem to have hit, it ain't going to hit
us for another year or so and three years for me. I mean, I, as people say, people ask me about Ali, they go, so why Ali now? And I go, I started this in 2014. What are you talking about? I didn't, you know, Black Lives Matter, Me Too, it's not there, but they're all relevant at, you know, everything rhymes. If people ever reached out to you and said like, from other countries or other parts of the globe and said like, can you tell really great stories about America?
But we have this going on over here. We would love if you would tell this story about what's happening in our country. But you know, it's interesting, the longest film that's ever been shown at the Cannes Film Festival is not Shoah, which is a phenomenal film. But our series on the Second World War called The War that came out in 2007. But it's American-centric though. And people, yeah, it was completely American-centric and we told the story of the greatest cataclysm in human history from the point of view of four geographically distributed American towns.
But it was this amazing group of people like a little United Nations that went from one screening room to the other as Cannes moved it from a big screening room in the main building to smaller rooms in that same building. And some people just sort of gave up their agenda and watched it and then went back to Denmark or then went back to Japan and said, we want to do this same sort of stuff. But our films play really well. The Civil War and now Ali and Jazz have gone all over the place. And what was great is that people felt that the Civil War series, I got this from Canadians
and Mexicans as well as everybody else. Ah, this is the Rosetta Stone. I finally kind of understand my complicated neighbor to the south. Yeah. You know, that was the general letter from Canadians. I didn't learn American history in the same way. I'm a big fan of history as students and it's exclusively pretty much what I read. And I've had to sort of educate myself on American history as I got older because and
of course your film was instrumental in helping me understand the Civil War and the intricacies. But I will say, I've often thought, I wish that Ken Burns would make a movie about Eastern Europe because I think I am right now, by the way. Are you are? Yeah. I'm making a film called the US and the Holocaust. And it's what we knew and when we knew it, what we did, what we didn't do it. But the central story is from is Poland.
Yes. Yes. Those stories, Poland, ethnic polls in the Ukraine. If you could start getting into that, we could really start understanding why the world is the way it is today. Stay tuned next fall. Next fall. Oh my God.
Ken, I'm coming over. Are there any other subjects or things that you will not touch or go near or don't want to? No, no, no. I mean, it's, I have up until now been entirely American history and it's, and what I tell people is that I'm a filmmaker. I'm not trained in history. I, you know, I took a Russian history course my first year of college.
The last time I took American history course was 11th grade, you know, when they put a gun to your head and make you take it. I love it, but I am a storyteller and I just happen to work in history the way somebody might work, a painter might work in oil as opposed to watercolor or do still lifes as opposed to landscapes. And that's it. And it works out pretty well because the word history is mostly made up of the word story plus hi, which is a good way to begin a story.
And that's what I've been doing. I am, I have to admit the team, my oldest daughter Sarah Burns and her husband, David McMahon and I, we made the Central Park Five and Jackie Robinson, IEP to film they did called Eastlake Meadows that came out last year about a public housing story, Atlanta, horrible, amazing, transcendent story. But we've done this Ali thing together and the next thing we're doing is our first non-American, my first non-American topic on Leonardo da Vinci. Wow.
I can't wait. You know, a gay bastard who, you know, is arguably, you know, in the running for the person of the last millennium. Yeah. Sean, was the title of your autobiographical one act? Absolutely. Ken and I are working on that. Yeah.
Hey, Ken, was Lincoln gay? I don't know. You know, how do we know? You know, there's what you're referring to, Sean, is that his partner, Joshua Speed, they exchange letters that are intimate and fill of, I can't wait till you get to the end tonight where we could be able to touch and hold each other. And so there was this presumption that the language of intimacy, which is true of women and of people in general, I don't know.
Jesus, Sean, don't put them on the spot. It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter, Sean. Why put them on the spot? And you know, and also... Hey, Ken is with Jim Neighbors gay. Yeah.
Hey, Ken, did George Washington's mouth really stink? No, you know, he did not have wooden teeth, by the way, guys. And he did tell lies, everybody lies, and he couldn't throw a dollar coin across the baton. Can I ask you about the filmmaking part of it? You're the... I don't mean to dork out for a second, but you're... The way in which you light and literally the focal length you use on a lot of your interviews,
嘿，肯，乔治·华盛顿的嘴真的臭吗？不，顺便告诉你们，他没有木牙。而且他也确实说过谎，人人都说谎，他也根本不可能把一枚美元硬币扔过波托马克河。我能问一下关于电影制作方面的问题吗？你是一位……我不是故意要表现得像个书呆子，但你的……你在很多访谈中所使用的布光方式，以及字面意义上的焦距，
the shallow depth of field, the single source lighting, the music that you choose... The single camera. The single camera, yeah, whether it be, you know, a tiny piano or even your use of the Beastie Boys mix up in the addendum to the baseball thing, the 10th inning, I mean, talk to me about your taste in filmmaking and your working, your enjoyment of working with multiple departments to shape that experience for the audience. It's a great question, and you've asked a lot of questions, you know, maybe, you know, if style is the authentic application of technique, right?
浅景深，单一光源布光，你选择的音乐……单机位。单机位，对，不管是，你知道的，一架小钢琴，还是你在棒球纪录片《第十局》的附录中对野兽男孩（Beastie Boys）歌曲的使用，我的意思是，跟我聊聊你的电影制作审美品味，以及你如何享受与多个部门合作，为观众塑造这种体验。这是一个很好的问题，你问了很多问题，你知道，也许，你知道，如果风格是对技术的真实运用，对吧？
If somebody has a... Oh, that's a style. It just means that you've used the tools at your disposal in a way that seems to be authentic or genuine, organic, consistent. And then you can stand in a room of Cezanne paintings and go, wow, they're all different if you go up close, but they share something which is an authenticity coming from one person. So we all, as filmmakers, have lots of techniques at our disposal. I could reduce it for clarity to eight.
如果一个人有……哦，那是一种风格。这只是意味着你以一种显得真实、真诚、有机且一致的方式使用了你手头上的工具。然后你可以站在一屋子塞尚的画作前说，哇，如果你走近看，它们各不相同，但它们共享着某种东西，那就是来自同一个人的真实性。所以我们所有作为电影人的人，手头都有很多技术。为了清晰起见，我可以把它精简为八种。
They're for visual and for oral, and the visual are obvious, still photographs and energetic exploring of them, trying to will them alive, trusting that they had a past and a future to the arrested moment that they represented, footage, live cinematography of the now quiet whatever you want to say, and interviews. And then orally, you have a third person narrator, you have first person voices, you have sound effects as complicated as a feature film, and you have music. Music, Jason, is the art of the invisible, as Wynton Marsalis describes. It's the only art form that you don't see.
它们分为视觉和听觉，视觉方面很明显，静态照片以及对它们的充满活力的探索，试图赋予它们生命，坚信它们所代表的定格瞬间拥有过去和现在，还有影像、当下安静的现场电影摄影（随便你想怎么称呼），以及访谈。而在听觉方面，你有第三人称旁白，你有第一人称配音，你有像故事片一样复杂的音效，还有音乐。音乐，杰森，正如温顿·马萨利斯所描述的，是看不见的艺术。它是唯一一种你看不见的艺术形式。
And so it works faster than any other one. And so what we do is we, in our process, we don't have a set research and writing period that produces a script that informs shooting and editing. However improvisational you might be within the context of those, we never stop researching and we never stop writing, and it makes us corrigible to the end. But more importantly, we don't add the music at the end. We bring it up to early in the editing, if not just before the editing process, so that the music, its pace and rhythm, its dynamism drives the scene.
所以它的起效比任何其他东西都快。因此，在我们的制作过程中，我们没有一个固定的研究和写作阶段来产出剧本，然后指导拍摄和剪辑。无论你在这些过程的语境中可能多么即兴，我们从不停止研究，也从不停止写作，这让我们直到最后都能够不断修正。但更重要的是，我们不会在最后才加入音乐。我们在剪辑的早期阶段，甚至就在剪辑过程开始之前，就把音乐引入进来，这样音乐的步伐、节奏和活力就能推动整个场景。
And it may be authentic to that period. It may be using, you know, Beastie Boys, or it may be using rap in a later period. But it also may be free and liberated from that. The most memorable tune from the Civil War is not from the Civil War's period. Everything else was, either a folk tune, a hymn, or a marching song, except for this one thing, a Shokan farewell, which was written by one of my session musicians that bridges the gap, a Jewish guy from the Bronx who wrote the most beautiful Scotch Irish lament I've ever heard, a Shokan farewell.
它可能忠实于那个时代。它可能使用，你知道的，野兽男孩的音乐，或者在后来的时期使用说唱。但它也可能从中解放出来，不受其束。南北战争中最难忘的曲调并不是来自南北战争时期。其他所有东西都是，要么是民谣、圣歌，要么是进行曲，除了这唯一的一首，一首由我的录音室乐手创作的《肖坎告别曲》，它填补了代沟，一个来自布朗克斯的犹太人写出了我听过最美的苏格兰-爱尔兰挽歌——《肖坎告别曲》。
So what we're doing is we want it just to work and we'll just use whatever works. And this Muhammad Ali thing has got, it's got Philip Glass, it's got some original compositions by this kid, wonderful composer named Jaleel Beetz, a guy we've worked with named Dave Sierra, lots of R&B, lots of soul, lots of funk, you know, and then some rap and other stuff. And sometimes we import Jaleel Beetz back to the early sixties when there wouldn't have been anything like this, you know, to animate a fight, or maybe we're using it authentically that this is the year this guitar riff from Jimi Hendrix came out, so let's use that.
所以我们在做的是，我们希望它能起作用，我们会使用任何管用的东西。而这部关于穆罕默德·阿利的片子有，它有菲利普·格lass的音乐，它有一些由一个叫贾利勒·比茨的年轻天才作曲家创作的原创作品，还有一个与我们合作过名叫戴夫·谢拉的人的音乐，大量的R&B、大量的灵歌、大量的放克，你知道的，然后还有一些说唱和其他东西。有时候我们会把贾利勒·比茨的音乐引入到60年代早期，当时本不该有任何类似的东西，你知道的，用来给一场比赛配动画，或者也许我们是在真实地使用它，因为这是吉米·亨德里克斯的吉他riff问世的那一年，所以我们就用那个。
But that's the same thing is true of, I'm finishing Benjamin Franklin, the stuff that we're using is stuff from the 18th century that he would have heard, or that it would have been composed for an instrument called the Glass Armonica that he invented. I mean, music is the most important element in a way because it undergirds everything. But remind me, I think you just said it, you do pick some things or compose some things if you're not using needle drops, as they say, before you see the footage even that inspires. That's how we start editing. I mean, for Civil War, just to give you an example, I went into old hymnals and old
但本杰明·富兰克林纪录片也是如此，我们正在使用的东西是18世纪他会听到的东西，或者是为他发明的一种叫做玻璃琴的乐器所创作的东西。我的意思是，从某种程度上说，音乐是最重要的元素，因为它支撑着一切。但提醒我一下，我想你刚才说过，如果你不使用现成音轨（俗称needle drops）的话，你确实会在看到启发你的素材之前，就挑选某些东西或创作某些东西。我们就是这样开始剪辑的。我的意思是，对于《南北战争》，举个例子，我翻阅了旧的赞美诗集和旧的
song books, and I had somebody plunk them out on the piano, and whenever something hit me, I go that one. And then we go into the studio with Session Musician and probably do 30 different recordings, some of them a single hand on a piano, rubato, untethered to any kind of pace, some of them adding different instrumentation, sometimes subtracting that instrumentation, sometime ensemble. And that music will then inform the edit. Yeah.
歌本，我让某人在钢琴上把它们弹出来，每当有什么触动我的时候，我就说“就这首”。然后我们和录音室乐手一起进棚，大概做了30种不同的录音，有些是单手在钢琴上弹奏的自由节拍（rubato），不被任何速度所束缚，有些是加入不同的乐器，有时减去那些乐器，有时是合奏。然后这段音乐将指导剪辑。对。
And Jason, I have literally extended a sentence so that the words fit the phrase of music, and I've cut a sentence so that the words fit the phrase of music because music is God. I love. Really quick, this is, I think this is kind of interesting, Steven Spielberg in E.T., so he heard John Williams score at the end of the movie. John scored it before he saw the movie, and Steven loved, he didn't want to cut any of it. That's why the long goodbye between Elliot and E.T., it's very, very, very long because
杰森，我甚至曾延长过一个句子，好让字词契合音乐的乐句；我也曾剪短过一个句子，好让字词契合音乐的乐句，因为音乐就是上帝。我爱。顺便说一句，这非常，我觉得这挺有趣的，史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格在拍《E.T.外星人》时，他在电影结尾听到了约翰·威廉姆斯的配乐。约翰在看电影之前就把配乐做好了，史蒂芬非常喜欢，他不想删掉其中的任何一部分。这就是为什么埃利奥特和E.T.之间的漫长告别会那么、那么、那么长，因为
Steve Spielberg didn't want to cut one single note of it. He knows. He gets it because at some point, if you think about scoring as a mathematical term, that means you're all watching the film, you got headphones and you're looking, and you want to have that beat at exactly this and that, and we don't do that. We'd rather move the action to the beat that is already there. That's part of the authenticity. I remember even on our little show we did in Venice, a Netflix show called Flaked, we
斯蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格不想删掉它的任何一个单音符。他懂。他完全理解，因为有时如果你把配乐看作一个数学术语，那就意味着你们所有人都在看着电影，戴着耳机盯着画面，你希望那个节拍精确地落在这样或那样的时间点上，而我们不这样做。我们宁愿把动作移到已经存在的那个节拍上去。这也是真实性的一部分。我记得甚至在我们当年在威尼斯做的那部小剧里，一部叫做《随波逐流》的Netflix剧集中，我们
had, I always knew that we were going to end the whole series on this song, Range Life, by Pavement and the great Steve Malchemist who actually scored the show as well, but I always wanted to, and I didn't tell him until the very end of the edit process of the second season, I said, I've always wanted to use Range Life, and I hope you're okay with that. And he was like, yeah, and so we shot, we had this sort of single shot of me riding my bicycle through Venice, and we shut all these intersections off and set around, and then we had this really sneaky little edit as I passed this van, but we thought that
拥有，我一直都知道我们将以这首歌来结束整部剧，那就是Pavement乐队的《Range Life》，以及伟大的史蒂夫·马尔克姆斯，他实际上也为这部剧做了配乐，但我一直想用，而且直到第二季剪辑工作的尾声我才告诉他，我说，我一直想用《Range Life》，希望你不会介意。他的反应是，好的，于是我们拍摄了，我们有这样一个长镜头，拍我骑着自行车穿过威尼斯，我们封锁了所有这些路口，四处转悠，然后当我骑过这辆面包车时，我们做了一个非常隐蔽的小剪辑，但我们认为
we'd time it anyway. We get into post and it's just not quite long enough to fit for where I wanted to hit. So we did a lot of trickery and extended shots and extended little pieces because of like, it has to, it cannot be one fucking beat off, it has to be exactly to Steve's song. Yeah, intact. That's the most important thing. You've got to serve the music, even though it is in the film process traditionally, not an afterthought, but something done at the end.
无论如何我们都会对准时间。等我们进入后期制作时，发现它长度稍微不够，无法契合我想要切入的位置。所以我们做了一些手脚，延长了镜头并延长了一些小片段，因为这必须，它绝对不能错乱哪怕一个该死的节拍，它必须完全契合史蒂夫的歌。没错，保持完整。这是最最重要的事。你必须服务于音乐，尽管在传统电影制作流程中，音乐不是事后诸葛亮，而是最后才做的事情。
And I think it has to be, it's not icing on the cake, it's fudge, it's baked in there. They sent me a little screener of the Muhammad Ali documentary film that I'm so excited to watch. Well, I know, I've got it, by the way, I've got it, you guys. It's as excellent as you thought it would be and hoped it would be and even more so. And it occurred to me, Muhammad Ali, I mean, we live in a day and age now where we have access to, for any sort of, you know, especially living figure, there's a tremendous amount of documentation of that person's life.
而且我认为它必须是这样，它不是蛋糕上的糖霜，它是软糖，它是直接烤进蛋糕里的。他们给我发了一个穆罕默德·阿利纪录片的小样，我兴奋得不行。哦，我知道，我有，顺便说一句，各位，我拿到了。它和你们想象的、希望的一样优秀，甚至有过之而无不及。这让我想到，穆罕默德·阿利，我的意思是，我们生活在这样一个时代，我们可以接触到，对于任何一种，你知道的，尤其是健在的人物，都有着极其大量的关于这个人一生的文献资料。
There's video and film and et cetera, and photographs. Muhammad Ali, and again, correct me if I'm wrong, because I'm wrong a lot. There are a lot of photographs, there is a lot of video of him and he must have been one of the first people of whom there was a lot of these things that in existence. Is that right? You'd be surprised, he is one of the most photographed and interviewed person, he's such good copy. But I think what we tend to do is because of the time I'm given, we can let go of our
有视频、电影等等，还有照片。穆罕默德·阿利，再次说明，如果我错了请纠正我，因为我经常犯错。有很多照片，有大量关于他的视频，他一定是最早拥有如此大量这类影像资料存在于世的人之一。是这样吗？你会大吃一惊的，他是被拍摄和采访最多的人之一，他太具有新闻价值了。但我认为我们倾向于做的是，由于给予我的时间，我们可以放下我们
own preconceptions. Sometimes we're fitting Muhammad Ali into our thought. There are lots of great documentaries on him that I love. They're mostly about a particular fighter. A couple years, we wanted to do soup to nuts, birth and boyhood, Louisville, segregated, Jim Crow, Kentucky, to Death by Parkinson's five years ago, not that long ago in a suburb of Phoenix, Arizona. That's our comprehensive thing.
自己的先入为主之见。有时我们是在把穆罕默德·阿利塞进我们的思想中。有很多关于他的优秀纪录片我都非常喜欢。它们大多是关于一个特定拳手的。而几年前，我们想要做到面面俱到，从出生和童年，肯塔基州路易斯维尔隔离的吉姆·克劳法时期，一直讲到五年前因帕金森综合症去世，那其实并不久远，在亚利桑那州菲尼克斯的一个郊区。这就是我们全面性的做法。
What we were able to find by spending the seven years doing it is all of this material that you wouldn't necessarily have. It doesn't serve a purpose. It belies the thing that at this point he was supposed to be this way or that way, valuable, and then he's despised for that volubility because athletes aren't supposed to brag and certainly not black athletes. That's not our definition, but he's redefining what a black manhood means. Maybe Jackie Robinson, a subject I've treated a few times, was the earlier generation.
通过花费七年时间去制作，我们所能找到的是所有这些你本来不一定会拥有的素材。它没有服务于某个单一的目的。它打破了这样一种成见：即在这个节点上，他本该是这样或那样的，很有价值，然后他又因为这种多话而招人唾弃，因为运动员是不应该自吹自擂的，黑人运动员更是如此。这并不是我们的定义，但他正在重新定义黑人男子气概的含义。也许杰基·罗宾逊——我曾处理过几次的一个题材——是更早一代的代表。
This is an entirely new one. He joins the nation of Islam, the separatist, hardly Islamic cult. It's just a cult. He's about separation when Americans are finally getting hip to the mainstream integrationist movement of the civil rights. Then he refuses the draft, so he's this pariah, and he works his way back in interesting ways. You want the music to reflect that, but you also want the footage. You don't go looking for never before seen or that because you want it to work.
这是一个全新的一代。他加入了伊斯兰民族组织，那个分离主义的、勉强算是伊斯兰的邪教。它其实就是个邪教。当美国人终于开始赶上民权运动的主流一体化浪潮时，他却在主张分离。然后他拒绝服兵役，于是他成了社会弃儿，但他以有趣的方式重新赢回了地位。你希望音乐能反映这一点，但你也希望影像资料能做到这一点。你不会刻意去寻找从未公开过的东西，因为你只想让它起作用。
Everything has to serve the telling of the story, but you realize that we are so complicated. As Whitman said, we contain multitudes. Do I contradict myself? Ali does that, and there's nothing wrong with that. It just downstairs in the main cockpit of the editing room in Neon, in cursive lower case it says it's complicated. There isn't a filmmaker in the world who doesn't, when a scene is working, want to go, don't touch it, but when we find new and contradictory information, we just go, okay, let's make
一切都必须服务于故事的讲述，但你会意识到我们是如此复杂。正如惠特曼所说，我们包罗万象。我是否与自己矛盾？阿利就是这样，这没有什么不对。霓虹公司剪辑室的主控制室楼下，就用草体小写字母写着“情况很复杂”。世上没有哪个电影人在场景运作良好时不想说“别碰它”，但当我们发现新的、矛盾的信息时，我们只会说，好吧，让我们让它
it even more complicated. Let's add undertoe if it's true to that story. The access to that unique material, though, is it just a question of you have the luxury of taking more time to seek it out and find it, or is it a question of licensing it, and do you have to pay for it before you say you're going to use it? No. I don't want to get into the weeds of the business of it all. Yes, you do.
变得更加复杂。如果符合那个故事，就让我们加入暗流。然而，获取这些独特素材的问题，仅仅在于你是否有奢侈的时间去寻找和发掘它，还是说这是一个版权问题，在你宣布要使用它之前必须为此付费？不。我不想陷入商业运作的细节泥潭中。不，你肯定想。
Please come and visit us while we're editing. I would love that. We have time code and watermarks. You got to look through a lot of stuff to see it. You would presume that filmmaking is architectural, that is, you're building something. While I have scaffolding and false work that will be taken away eventually, it's just additive. It's subtractive. I live in New Hampshire here.
请在我们剪辑的时候来看看我们。我太乐意了。我们有时间码和水印。你得浏览大量的东西才能看到它们。你可能会认为电影制作就像建筑一样，也就是说，你在建造某样东西。虽然我有脚手架和临时支撑，它们最终会被拆除，但这不仅仅是做加法。它是做减法。我就住在新罕布什尔州。
We make maple syrup that takes 40 gallons of sap to make one gallon of syrup, and that's what it is. Our editing room floor is covered with really good scenes, and so we're pulling out stuff and trying to honor the negative space of creation, what's not there. We need the time. It's not a luxury. It's a necessity in order to collect all the material. At any given moment, Jason, there may be 40 other photographs that could fit in at that
我们制作枫糖浆，需要40加仑的树液才能制成1加仑的糖浆，事情就是这样。我们的剪辑室地板上铺满了非常棒的场景，所以我们在抽丝剥茧，试图尊重创作中的负空间，也就是那些不在画面的东西。我们需要时间。这不是一种奢侈。为了收集所有的资料，这是必不可少的。在任何给定的时刻，杰森，都可能有另外40张照片适合放在那个
moment. It's rarely that case, but you have those kind of options, and you're just trying to figure it. Sometimes you're making a decision, well, that's got a light background, and a dark background has a warmth, and the psychology of the reception of that image is that, and I'm saying, let's just change it. I know the other one's sharper and a little bit better, and we're looking through watermarks and time code.
时刻。这种情况虽然罕见，但你确实有这种选择空间，而你只是在试图理清它。有时候你在做一个决定，嗯，那个背景是亮的，而暗色背景有一种温暖感，人们对那个图像接受的心理学就是这样，而我说，我们换掉它吧。我知道另一个更清晰也稍微好一点，而我们正在透过水印和时间码仔细搜寻。
What would you do with 40 gallons of sap? First of all, I was just going to say that it's funny, all of my films, all the good scenes ended up on the cutting room floor. All right, back to the show. I will say it does seem overwhelming, but also I can see your passion for even as you talk about it, you have this excitement about all of it. Process, it's process. It's not the film.
你会拿40加仑的树液怎么办？首先，我本来想说，这很有趣，我所有的电影，所有精彩的场景最后都落在了剪辑室地板上。好了，回到节目中来。我得说，这确实让人感到压倒一切，但同时我也能看到你的热情，甚至当你在谈论它时，你对这一切都充满了兴奋感。过程，这就是过程。它不是电影本身。
So whenever it comes out, if it says Ali on it, well, that's for you guys, right? But I'm doing the same thing. Somebody asked me earlier about putting my head on the pillow, like all I want to know is that I made a film better that day. Yeah, right, right. That's so great. The best moment was mixing the Civil War series, where you know how it is, you're laying in the different tracks, and we hadn't laid down the gunshot at Ford's Theater, and we'd done
所以无论它什么时候上映，如果上面写着《阿利》，嗯，那是给你们看的，对吧？但我做的是同一件事。刚才有人问我关于枕着枕头入睡的事，我只想知道那一天我把一部电影拍得更好了。没错，对，对。太棒了。最棒的时刻是混音《南北战争》系列的时候，你知道那是怎么回事，你把不同的音轨铺进去，当时我们还没把福特剧院的枪声放进去，而我们已经完成了
everything else. We had the arena stage theater that put on Our American Cousin, all the tiny Victorian at Custodale be gone, and door slams, and footfalls, and laughter, and people coughing in the narrator, and whatever the music was, but we hadn't laid in the bullet, and I was saying, okay, it's all analog. Back in the Mixer's lead actor, great, great feature film mixer, Woody and Spike, and Marty and everybody, and it sound one in the Brill Building, and we're going, and he looks around at me, and I yell, stop, just before it comes to rest on the bullet.
所有其他的工作。我们有举办《我们的美国表亲》演出的竞技场舞台剧场，古斯托代尔的所有微型维多利亚风格都消失了，还有关门声、脚步声、笑声、旁白中的咳嗽声，以及无论是什么音乐，但我们还没把子弹声放进去。我说，好吧，全都是模拟的。回到混音师的主力演员，非常非常优秀的故事片混音师伍迪、斯派克、马蒂和所有人，在布里尔大厦的Sound One，我们正进行着，他转过身看着我，就在声音即将停在子弹落下的那一刻，我大喊：停！
And we just sat there, tears rolling down our cheeks, and then I nodded to him. He went back, laid the bullet down, but the best moment was just for a moment, not having killed Abraham, like it just held him from death, you know, from the mouth. That's interesting. Yeah, you get to play with history. Yeah, it's just amazing stuff, you know, the laws of storytelling, as you know, are the same for me and Steven Spielberg, and I talked to him about it, I interviewed him on a stage in Washington, and we realized it's the same thing.
我们就那样坐在那儿，眼泪顺着面颊滚落，然后我向他点了点头。他转回身，把子弹声放了进去，但最棒的时刻仅仅在于那一瞬间，仿佛还没有杀死亚伯拉罕，就像是把他从死亡边缘拉了回来，你知道的，从鬼门关前。这很有趣。对，你得以与历史玩耍。对，这真是了不起的东西，你知道，故事讲述的法则，如你所知，对我跟史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格来说是一样的，我和他谈过这个，我在华盛顿的一个舞台上采访过他，我们意识到这就是同一回事。
He can make shit up, and I can't, but it's the same laws of storytelling. Yeah, right, sure. But your ability to create these incredibly compelling moments, having your hands tied with the fact of the story, in other words, you can't embellish a big, you know, crescendo ending for dramatic satisfaction. You are a slave to what the story was and what the ending is, and so your ability to craft the lead-up to and the framing of is unmatched, and I'd say that in front of Spielberg. I mean, it's just incredible what you do, and I just can't thank you enough for doing
他可以胡编乱造，而我不能，但故事讲述的法则是一样的。没错，确实如此。但你有能力创造出这些令人难以置信的引人注目的时刻，同时又被故事的真实性束缚住双手，换句话说，你不能为了戏剧效果而去润饰一个宏大的、以高潮结尾的结局。你是故事原本模样及其结局的奴隶，所以你精心铺垫和构图的能力是无与伦比的，即使当着斯皮尔伯格的面我也敢这么说。我的意思是，你所做的事简直不可思议，我真的感激不尽你能
it. Thank you. Thank you. You know, Shelby Foote in the Civil War called me up and he said, God's the greatest dramatist. Because you just, you know, suddenly you win the war on Friday, good Friday, and you figure that by Tuesday night you got, you're ready, you got some free time, you'll go to the theater. Yeah.
做到这一切。谢谢你。谢谢你。你知道，《南北战争》里的谢尔比·福特曾打电话给我，他说，上帝才是最伟大的戏剧家。因为你看，你突然在星期五——耶稣受难日赢得了战争，然后你觉得到星期二晚上你就有空了，你有一些空闲时间，你会去看个戏。对。
You can't make that shit up. I forgot to mention Shelby Foote. I stopped drinking because of Shelby Foote, because we'd be on the seventh, you know, bourbon, and I'd be under the table, and he'd be talking away, and I'd be like, oh, man, I can't do this anymore. Where did you get the discipline, the instinct to ignore good in the pursuit of great, you know, because a lot of people will just stop at good, and that's just, you know, good stuff.
你可编不出那种破事儿。我忘了提谢尔比·福特了。我戒酒就是因为谢尔比·福特，因为我们喝到第七杯，你知道，波旁威士忌，然后我就钻到桌子底下去了，而他还在滔滔不绝地讲个不停，我就想，哦，天哪，我再也不能这样了。你是从哪里获得这种纪律和本能，在追求伟大的过程中去忽略优秀呢？你知道的，因为很多人会在优秀那里就停下来，而那也只是，你知道的，好东西。
I think moving up here helped me 42 years ago this week. I had finished shooting most of the Brooklyn Bridge film, and I needed a real job in New York, and I could easily put the film footage up on top of the refrigerator, and then boom, wake up, and I'm 45 and didn't finish that novel the way they had got. So I moved up here where I could live for nothing, and the first film got nominated for an Academy Award, and people said, come back to New York, go into LA, and go, no, I'm gonna stay here, because I realized that that dynamic of what we do required an amount of time, and you could build a community of people who have the patience and understand
我想搬到这里来对我有所帮助，就在42年前的这周。我拍完了《布鲁克林大桥》这部电影的大部分镜头，我需要在纽约找一份真正的正经工作，我完全可以把电影素材往冰箱上一搁，然后砰的一声，一觉醒来我45岁了，却没有像他们那样完成那部小说。所以我搬到了这里，在这里我可以花极少的钱生活，第一部电影就获得了奥斯卡奖提名，人们说，回纽约吧，去洛杉矶吧，我说，不，我要留在这里，因为我意识到我们所做的那种动力需要大量的时间，而且你可以建立一个拥有耐心、理解并尊重这个过程的社群。
their respect for the process. So when we finish it, but we're doing the same thing every day, we're just trying to make a film better. Do you live in a small town up there, Kim? It is like, looks like Courier and I. Yeah, and do people like, do people point, stand up and go, that's where that crazy filmmaker lives? He lives in that.
所以当我们完成它时，我们每天都在做同样的事情，我们只是试图让一部电影变得更好。你住在那里的小镇上吗，肯？看起来就像柯里尔和艾夫斯的画作一样。对，人们会，人们会指指点点，站起来说，那个疯狂的电影人就住在那里吗？他就住在那个地方？
People drive by, but you know, they leave me alone. It's really great. So any kind of celebrity plus 50 cents gets a cup of coffee. You know what I mean? It's like, they care more about whether if my neighbor's not feeling well, I shovel their drive, you know? Yeah, of course. No, no, I spent enough time in New England to know that the fact that you're a celebrity
人们开车路过，但你知道的，他们不打扰我。这真的很棒。所以任何名气加上50美分也只能换来一杯咖啡。你知道我的意思吗？这就好比，他们更关心的是，如果我的邻居身体不舒服，我会帮他们铲雪，你知道吗？对，当然。不，不，我在新英格兰待的时间足够长了，我知道你是个名人的事实
makes them want to pay less attention to you. The biggest thing that happened is about 10 or 15 years ago, I was giving some talk in town, and I said, look, I realize that maybe my great, great, great grandchildren have a chance to be on the volunteer fire department, right? Yeah. About two or three years ago, a guy that I know who comes at four in the morning to fix your cracked pipes, who's a volunteer on the EMS, came and brought me a T-shirt that said Walpole Volunteer Fire Department.
反而让他们更不想过多关注你。发生的最大一件事大约是10到15年前，我在镇上做了一场演讲，我说，听着，我意识到也许我的玄孙们有机会加入志愿消防队，对吧？对。大约两三年前，我认识的一个人在凌晨四点来修你裂开的水管，他是急救医疗服务队的志愿者，他来给我送了一件印有“沃波尔志愿消防队”字样的T恤。
It's like, I died and gone to heaven. It was just like. That's so crazy, because Jason used to often have to fix his crack pipe at 4 AM, but I used to, I was going to know it was going to take that one. Man, I didn't even see that either. I know. I'm sorry about it. Is there a filmmaker Ken that you admire?
这就好像我死后进入了天堂。那种感觉简直是。太疯狂了，因为杰森以前经常不得不在凌晨四点去修他裂开的水管，但我曾经，我本来就知道会扯到那个上面去。老天，我甚至都没看到那个梗。我知道。我很抱歉。肯，有没有哪个你所钦佩的电影人？
Is there a doc in your genre, in your world that you're like, how can I? Oh, yeah, lots. I love Fred Wiseman, who does Cinema Verité. I've dabbled in it. The Central Park Five is as close to the film I made on these dyslexic kids, learning to memorize and recite the Gettysburg Address. I love that. I love what Errol Morris does, the highly stylized stuff of that.
在你的流派、你的世界里，有没有哪部纪录片让你觉得，我怎么才能拍出来？哦，有啊，很多。我喜欢弗雷德·怀斯曼，他拍摄真实电影（Cinema Verité）。我也涉猎过。《中央公园五人案》跟我为那些有读写困难、学习背诵和朗诵葛底斯堡演说词的孩子们拍的电影很接近。我喜欢那个。我喜欢埃罗·莫里斯的作品，那种高度风格化的东西。
Bernard Herzog is a good friend of mine, and he and I are like total opposites of what we do. He's a total opposite of everybody, it seems. We were on a panel once, and he looked at me, and he said, I'm interested in an ecstatic truth. My friend Ken is interested in an emotional truth, and he turned to Michael Moore, and he said, you, with your big belly hanging out, you're interested in a physical truth. And he looked at D.A. Pennebaker, the great Cinema Verité guy, and said, and you, you,
韦纳·赫尔佐格是我的好朋友，他和我是我们所做事情的完全对立面。他似乎和所有人都完全对立。我们曾一同参加一个座谈会，他看着我，然后说，我感兴趣的是一种狂喜的真理。我的朋友肯感兴趣的是一种情感的真理，接着他转向迈克尔·摩尔，说，你，挺着个大肚子，你感兴趣的是一种物理的真理。然后他又看着D.A.彭尼贝克，那个伟大的真实电影先驱，说道，还有你，你，
I think you're my enemy. Cinema Verité is the cinema of accountants. Wow, my gosh. I don't know who that is. You've got to see his film, My Best Fiend, which is Bernard Herzog's relationship with Klaus Kinski, which is just phenomenal. And Bernard Herzog, and I say this with a lot of respect and love, is a fucking nut job in the best way.
我想你是我的敌人。真实电影是会计的电影。哇，天哪。我不知道那是谁。你一定要看他的电影《我的最佳fiend》（我的好敌人），那是韦纳·赫尔佐格与克劳斯·金斯基的关系，简直太绝了。而且韦纳·赫尔佐格，我带着极大的尊重和爱意这样说，他真是一个极其疯狂的怪咖，以最好的方式。
In the best way. But so that must be an interesting, interesting. Well, he's gotten into documentaries after two or three decades, and still does features of, but he's really gotten into documentaries, and it's so different. And it's just he will run through every stop sign that I will politely put on the brakes and look both ways and proceed with caution, and he doesn't care. Do your kids want to do what dad does? Well, I've got four daughters.
以最好的方式。但这一定是一件很有趣、很有趣的事。嗯，他在经历了二三十年的剧情片创作后，开始涉足纪录片，并且仍然在拍剧情片，但他真的迷上了纪录片，而且风格如此迥异。他会闯过我礼仪周全地踩下刹车、左右看并谨慎前行的每一个停止标志，而他根本不在乎。你的孩子们想做爸爸做的事情吗？嗯，我有四个女儿。
The oldest, Sarah, has been working with me for 10 years, and her husband was working with me for longer. My second daughter, Lily, is the principal in Jack's Media, which does Samantha Bee and Daisy Sunmarow and Search Party and Broad City. Those are all her shit, and she's great. And then I got a 16-year-old gal who is interested in history, and a 10-year-old gal who makes movies. She goes, Dad, I'm going to make a movie, and I'll be right back.
最大的萨拉已经跟我工作了10年，她的丈夫跟我工作的时间更长。我的二女儿莉莉是杰克斯传媒（Jack's Media）的核心人物，这家公司制作了萨曼莎·比、黛西·孙玛罗、《搜寻死党》和《大城小妞》。这些全都是她的杰作，她太棒了。然后我有一个16岁的女孩对历史感兴趣，还有一个10岁的女孩自己拍电影。她说，爸爸，我要去拍部电影，我马上回来。
And she comes in two minutes and comes back with this thing. And I go, how did you do that? I can't even tie my shoes in there. Were you a great student in school? Yeah, I was pretty good, but I really thought I'd be an anthropologist, which is what my dad was. My mom was sick the whole time with cancer, died when I was 11. And this psychologist, maybe to answer the question earlier from Jason, I went to him
结果她两分钟就进进出出，带着这个东西回来了。我说，你是怎么做到的？我连系鞋带都花不了那么快。你在学校是个好学生吗？对，我挺不错的，但我真心以为我会成为一名人类学家，就像我父亲那样。我母亲一生都在与癌症搏斗，在我11岁时去世了。而这位心理学家，也许是为了回答刚才杰森的问题，我有一天去找了他，
one day, my late father-in-law, and he said, I seem to be keeping my mom alive. I couldn't remember to be present the date she died. He was always approaching and then receding. And he said, and I bet you as a kid, you blew out your candles wishing she'd come back alive. I said, how'd you know? She goes, look what you do for a living. You wake the dead. You make Abraham Lincoln and Jackie Robinson come alive.
我已故的岳父，他说，我似乎一直在让我妈妈活着。我总是记不清在她去世的那天要在场。他总是靠近然后又退缩。他说，我敢打赌你小时候吹蜡烛时，许愿让她活过来。我说，你怎么知道的？她说，看看你的谋生手段。你在唤醒死者。你让亚伯拉罕·林肯和杰基·罗宾逊活了过来。
Who do you think you're really trying to wake up? And so a lot of the passion is that if my mom hadn't died, we wouldn't be talking. If I hadn't gone to Hampshire College and met a couple of still photographers, Jerome Liebling and Elaine Mays, we wouldn't be talking. I wouldn't have had the guts to start my own company and say, no, I'm just going to do it my way. Every film I've made is a director's cup. The better way of putting it is, there are no complaints.
你觉得你真正想唤醒的是谁？所以这种热情很大程度上在于，如果我母亲没有去世，我们今天就不会坐在这里对话。如果我没有去汉普郡学院并遇到几位静态摄影师——杰罗姆·利布林和伊莲·梅斯，我们就不会坐在这里对话。我也不会有勇气创办自己的公司并说，不，我要按自己的方式去做。我拍的每一部电影都是导演剪辑版。换个更好的说法是，没有任何抱怨。
And the even better way is saying, if you don't like something, it's all my fault. And that's the way it should be. Yeah. Do you ever feel like being a bully and doing a two-hour documentary just so that you can wrap up the Academy Award with no competition whatsoever? No. You know what? I got nominated twice for Brooklyn Bridge, which was one hour.
更好的说法是，如果你不喜欢某些东西，那全都是我的错。事情本来就该如此。对。你有没有过那种像个恶霸一样做一部两小时纪录片，好把奥斯卡奖毫无竞争悬念地收入囊中的冲动？没有。你知道吗？我曾因《布鲁克林大桥》获得两次提名，那是一小时的。
And for Statue of Liberty, which was one hour. And we didn't win, which was fine. Wow. Third time's a charm. And then the Civil War, we had like a really great score, but somebody on the committee, just a couple of people blackballed us and it didn't even get nominated because it was quote TV. And then we were supposedly the lock for the Central Park Five film and it didn't even
还有《自由女神像》，那也是一小时的。我们没赢，不过没关系。哇。事不过三。然后是《南北战争》，我们有一分配极佳的配乐，但委员会里的某个人，仅仅是两三个人投了反对票，封杀我们，它甚至都没获得提名，因为它被称为所谓的“电视作品”。然后我们本被认为稳操胜券的《中央公园五人案》电影甚至都没能
make the final cut. So this is about feature films and the documentaries branch is, I think, trying to improve. And it doesn't matter. People said, well, don't you feel bad about having to get all these grants, make you give it to PBS? I said, no. I traded for a slightly smaller screen. I still go to festivals where we go every year to tell your eye, which is the best festival
进入最后的入围名单。所以这是关于故事片的事，而纪录片分支，我认为，正在努力改进。这根本无所谓。人们说，难道你不觉得为了筹集所有这些资助而不得不把它交给PBS感觉很糟糕吗？我说，不。我只是换了一个稍微小一点的屏幕。我依然去参加各种电影节，每年我们都会去特柳赖德，那是地球上最好的电影节，
on earth and get to Cannes sometimes and go to New York. And it's great. Do you take 95 when you go to New York? No, no, no, no. You take 91 down to the Merritt and then the Merritt to the Cross County, to the Cross County, to the West of Thailand. To the Sawmill. Well, Sawmill for two miles.
有时也会去戛纳，去纽约。这太棒了。你去纽约的时候走95号公路吗？不，不，不，不。你走91号公路南下到梅里特公园大道，然后从梅里特到克罗斯县公路，从克罗斯县，到西泰。到锯木厂河公园大道。呃，锯木厂河公园大道开两英里。
Right now. Yeah. Do you get to the Bronx? But don't rule it out because then you'll get screwed. Yeah. Okay. Ken, are you a Red Sox fan? Is the Pope Catholic?
就现在。对。你能到布朗克斯吗？但别把这条路排除在外，否则你会倒大霉的。对。好吧。肯，你是红袜队的球迷吗？教皇是天主教徒吗？
Yeah. Of course I am. I believe in rooting for the place. I've been in New England since 71. So when I went to college. Who was the bigger Red Sox fan? You or Doris Kearns? Good one.
对。我当然是。我坚信要支持本土球队。我从71年起就一直在新英格兰。所以当我上大学的时候。谁是更大的红袜队球迷？你还是多丽丝·卡恩斯·古德温？好问题。
Oh God. You know what? She had the earlier love of the Dodgers. Well, Mike Barnacle. Well, Mike is the best red, both of these people are good friends of mine. The love is the same and while he's pretty cool customer, Doris and I are as neurotic as you could possibly be about the Red Sox and I'm like, my latest thing is to step out and say not only does Big Poppy deserve to be in the Hall of Fame, but he's the greatest
哦，天哪。你知道吗？她对道奇队的爱开始得更早。嗯，迈克·巴纳克尔。嗯，迈克是最棒的红——这两个人都是我的好朋友。这份热爱是一样的，虽然他是个相当冷静的顾客，但我和多丽丝对红袜队的神经质简直到了无以复加的地步，而且我是那种，我最近的最新言论是站出来说，老大爹不仅配得上进入名人堂，而且他还是红袜队历史上最伟大的
Red Sox player ever. Wow. Because the way that will just bristle up the Ted Williams, Carl Yastramski crowd. But there's, you know, Babe Ruth, maybe, right? Yeah. Yeah. Three World Series. I will say this.
球员。哇。因为这种说法会彻底惹恼特德·威廉姆斯和卡尔·雅斯特尔姆斯基的拥趸。但你知道的，贝比·鲁斯也许算一个吧？对。对。三次世界大战——三次世界大战，三次世界大赛冠军。我得这么说。
I was at that game in 2004 when Big Poppy hit that home run when the Yankees were up 3-0. Yeah. David Cross. In fact, Jason was there, but Jason left early because he had to fly back to Hollywood because he had to go to a Hollywood elite party. But David Cross and I stayed. David Cross and I stayed and we watched that come, which was the greatest come back then.
我曾在2004年亲历那场比赛，当时洋基队以3比0领先，老大爹打出了那一记本垒打。对。大卫·克罗斯。事实上，杰森当时也在现场，但杰森提前离场了，因为他得坐飞机赶回好莱坞，去参加一个好莱坞名流派对。但我和大卫·克罗斯留下来了。我和大卫·克罗斯留下来观看了那场惊天大逆转，那是当时最伟大的逆转。
The greatest thing ever. I went on that first game when the Yankees went ahead fairly early, I just, I was in New York actually and I went to Lincoln Center because I'm friends with Winton and I just thought, okay, I'll drown and I was walking around and I kind of put it out of my mind figuring it was just like 0-3 the year before we just got screwed, it's over. And I watched this whole concert and then I hear this guy in the next seat, he goes, fuck, they're tied. And I went, what?
最伟大的事情。我去看了第一场比赛，当时洋基队相当早就取得了领先，我只是，我当时其实在纽约，我去了林肯中心，因为我和温顿是朋友，我只是想，好吧，我要在痛苦中淹没自己，我在四周闲逛，我把这事儿抛到了脑后，心想就像前一年0比3落后一样，我们又被坑了，一切都结束了。我看了整场音乐会，然后我听到隔壁座位的一个家伙说，操，他们打平了。我当时就想，什么？
And I ran out of Lincoln Center and I called my then wife and who hates baseball and she goes, it's a game of circumstances. I said, yeah, what the fuck is happening? Tell me what happened? She goes, I don't know, it's just tied. And then by the time I got into the subway and back, I sat there like red buttons in Hattari. Does that reference mean anything to you guys?
我跑出林肯中心，打电话给我当时的妻子，她讨厌棒球，她说，这就是一场充满变数的比赛。我说，对，到底他妈的发生什么了？告诉我发生什么了？她说，我不知道，反正就是打平了。然后等我坐上地铁赶回去时，我坐在那儿，就像电影《非洲寻宝记》（Hatari）里的雷德·巴顿斯一样。这个梗对你们有意义吗？
Red buttons. Okay. So there's a great John Ford film called Hattari about African guys and he designs this net that will let the rocket shoot over a tree so they can trap these monkeys that they'll take back to the zoo. And he's so nervous about it, he doesn't watch it. And so he misses this amazing thing and he spends the rest of the movie in his cup saying, you know, tell me about it again.
雷德·巴顿斯。好吧。所以有一部由约翰·福特执导的伟大电影叫《非洲寻宝记》，讲的是非洲的几个家伙，他设计了一个网，能让火箭射过一棵树，这样他们就能抓住这些猴子带回动物园。他对此紧张得要命，根本不敢看。结果他错过了这个惊人的时刻，电影剩下的时间他都郁郁寡欢地说，你知道的，再跟我讲讲当时的情形。
Anyway, it's great. And then I just didn't miss anything afterwards. My daughter and son-in-law were at the or future son-in-law were at the sixth game, the bloody sock game and it's incredible. So what that documentary did for me with baseball, you know, I'm a huge classical music fan and I'd love to become as passionate about jazz or even country music. If I watch jazz or if I watch the country music one, will I, will I get the same? Jason Singh, could anything make him passionate about anything?
总之，这太棒了。然后我之后什么都没错过。我女儿和女婿——或者说未来的女婿——去了第六场比赛，也就是血袜子那场比赛，简直难以置信。所以那部关于棒球的纪录片为我做到的事情是，你知道，我是个庞大的古典音乐迷，我很希望能对爵士乐甚至乡村音乐抱有同样的热情。如果我看了爵士乐或者乡村音乐的那部，我会，我会获得同样的……杰森说，有什么能让他对任何事物产生热情吗？
Go ahead. As long as Ken Burns does a film about it, I'm going to fall in love with it. He's aching to feel. If I, if I had that, that mythical dinner party, I'd invite Abraham Lincoln, but I'm more interested. I would invite Muhammad Ali and Louis Armstrong. Wow. So watch jazz first before country.
说吧。只要肯·吉尔斯拍一部关于它的电影，我就会爱上它。他渴望去感受。如果我，如果我举办那个神话般的晚宴，我会邀请亚伯拉罕·林肯，但我更感兴趣的是，我会邀请穆罕默德·阿利和路易斯·阿姆斯特朗。哇。所以先看爵士乐，然后再看乡村音乐。
No, they're all related. What commerce and convenience makes us put silos around this stuff. Yeah. Stop trying to rank everything. All of the great, the pantheon, the Mount Rushmore of country music all had black teachers right? Right. And when Ray Charles had creative control of an album for the first time, his first
不，它们都是相关的。商业和便利让我们在这些东西周围筑起了谷仓。对。别再试图给所有东西排名了。所有伟大的、乡村音乐的万神殿、拉什莫尔山上的巨头们，都有黑人老师，对吧？对。当雷·查尔斯第一次对一张专辑拥有创作控制权时，他第一张
album of his own design was modern sounds in country and western music. And the number one hit of 1962, the summer of 1962 is I Can't Stop Loving You by Ray Charles singing Don Gibson's country song. And it's a black soul singer singing a country voice. It is. Wow. It's unbelievable. And there's just no borders.
自己设计的专辑是《乡村和西部音乐中的现代之声》。而1962年的冠军单曲，1962年夏天的冠军单曲，就是雷·查尔斯演唱唐·吉布森的乡村歌曲《我无法停止爱你》。那是黑人灵歌歌手在用乡村唱法演唱。确实如此。哇。太不可思议了。而且根本没有界限。
Like the best selling country single of all time is by Lil Nas X, who is a black gay rapper. Wow. Wow. Yeah. I mean, that's what, this is where, look, here's my last stick, I promise, is that I've been making films for 45 years, almost 50 years about the US, but I've also been making films about us. And the thing I learned in country music, Jason, is that there's only us.
就像史上最畅销的乡村单曲是Lil Nas X的作品，他是一个黑人同性恋说唱歌手。哇。哇。我的意思是，这就是，看吧，这是我的最后绝招，我保证，那就是我制作关于美国的电影已经45年了，快50年了，但我也一直在制作关于“我们”的电影。我在乡村音乐中学到的东西，杰森，那就是只有“我们”。
There's no them. And if anyone tells you there's a them, which is what everybody's doing these days, run away from them. There's only us. Wow. Ken Burns. Great. What a way to end.
根本没有“他们”。如果任何人告诉你有一个“他们”——这正是如今每个人都在做的——离他们远点。只有“我们”。哇。肯·吉尔斯。太棒了。多么精彩的收尾。
Thank you so much. I mean, you're just, it's what an honor to have you. I don't know about these guys, but I could talk to you all day. No, same. You're saying it was who you wanted to. Nine parts. Nine parts. Nine parts.
非常感谢你。我的意思是，你简直是，能拥有你做嘉宾是多么大的荣幸啊。不知道这几位怎么想，但我能跟你聊上一整天。不，我也是。你刚才说那是你想……九集。九集。九集。
You want to do it? We've never had a guest. I don't think we've ever had a guest where we have talked over each other so much, trying to get in there with a question. That's right. The three of us just completely enamored with you, and I can't thank you enough for coming on. Yeah.
你想拍吗？我们从来没有过这样的嘉宾。我想我们从来没有过这样一个嘉宾，我们为了插话提问而互相抢话抢得这么厉害。没错。我们三个完全被你迷住了，我真是感激不尽你能来参加节目。对。
Salutations and all the incredible work you've done for the last 45, whatever it was. Thank you, Ken, for all of that work. Just really incredible, incredible body work. And so much more to come. I'm so excited about the Muhammad Ali documentary that's coming out in September. We're really excited about it. It's so great. Like I said, I just started it and just all wishing you all the best and so much success
向你致敬，感谢你过去45年里所做的一切不可思议的工作，无论那是多少年。肯，谢谢你付出的所有这些工作。真的是极其了不起、极其宏大的作品。而且未来还会有更多。我为即将于9月份上映的穆罕默德·阿利纪录片感到无比兴奋。我们对此真的超级兴奋。太棒了。就像我说的，我才刚开始看，祝你一切都好，取得巨大成功，
and all good things in your life, Ken. Thank you for being here. Really great. Thanks, Ken. Thanks. Great to be with you. Pleasure. Thank you so much, Ken.
愿你的人生充满美好的事物，肯。感谢你能来。真的太棒了。谢谢，肯。谢谢。很高兴能与你交流。荣幸之至。非常感谢你，肯。
Pleasure. Bye. Bye. Bye. Well, Scotty's obsessed. Obsessed with the Roosevelt's. He's seen it like 10 times. I have not seen that one.
荣幸之至。再见。再见。再见。斯科蒂真是着迷了。对罗斯福家族着迷。他大概看了10遍吧。我还没看过那部。
Oh, it's fantastic. Yeah. There's plenty of his that I haven't seen because he has been so prolific. But my God, the ones I have seen and there are a lot of them. It sounds like the only one you've seen is the baseball one. No, it's the one I talk about because it's just, you know, baseball is my passion. Because it's the one you've seen. You know what I'm going to do though?
哦，那部棒极了。对。他的作品里有很多我都没看过，因为他实在是太高产了。但天哪，我看过的那些，数量已经相当多了。听起来你唯一看过的那部就是棒球那部。不，那是我经常挂在嘴边谈论的部，因为那只是，你知道的，棒球是我的激情所在。因为那是你唯一看过的一部。你知道我要怎么做吗？
I'm going to watch each one of them. You don't have enough time. Yeah. No, I'm going to like one a night, one every other night. That's what I'm doing. Listen. No, no, no. I'm talking about like all of them though.
我要把它们每一部都看一遍。你的时间根本不够。对。不，我打算像这样，一晚看一部，或者每隔一晚看一部。这就是我要做的。听着。不，不，不。我是说要把它们全看完。
I mean, Vietnam's 10 parts. The war is 10 parts. I mean, it's. Do it all. Yeah. I would, I'll be there right there with you right after I finish driving back from Will's house after watching Ali. Will, I'm coming over for that.
我的意思是，越战那部有10集。《战争》有10集。我的意思是，这。全部看完。对。我会的，看完阿利之后，我从威尔家开车回来，就会立刻跟你一起看。威尔，我要去你那儿看。
Listen, the war is really good. Yeah. Vietnam is really, really good too. And I do want to watch jazz and country music too. Oh, really great. And Will, you will never beat that as a guest. That's, that's, that's your best, your best guest ever. He's such a fan of his.
听着，战争片真的很棒。是的。越南也是，真的非常棒。而且我也想看爵士乐和乡村音乐。噢，真的很棒。威尔，你再也不会找到比这更好的嘉宾了。那是，那是，那是你最好，最好的嘉宾。他是他的超级粉丝。
Yeah. Yeah. No, me too. But you know what? All of his filmmaking is completely fair and impartial. None of it is. Yeah. He's not, doesn't have an agenda.
对。对。不，我也是。但你知道吗？他所有的电影制作都完全公平且公正。没有一个是这样的。对。他没有，也没有什么政治意图。
Doesn't seem. Bias. Oh. Pretty good. Pretty good. Bias. Bias. Bias.
看起来没有。偏见。噢。相当不错。相当不错。偏见。偏见。偏见。
Bias. Smart. Smart. Bias. Smart. Bias. Smart. Bias.
偏见。聪明。聪明。偏见。聪明。偏见。聪明。偏见。
Smart. Bias. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry and Rob Amjarf. The next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music or by subscribing to Wondry Plus in the Wondry app. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。偏见。《SmartLess》由贝内特·巴巴科（Bennett Barbaco）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·安杰尔夫（Rob Amjarf）100%纯天然手工制作。下一集将在微周内在各大播客平台推出，或者你可以现在就在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上提前收听，或通过Wondry App订阅Wondry Plus。SmartLess。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。